- Well, I guess romance isn't dead.
Let us know in the comments
how you would propose to your sex doll.
- [Man] And that's a cut.
(bell ringing)
(coughing)
- Great job everybody, especially Ryan.
- Thank you.
- (laughs) Just kidding.
(everyone laughing)
You were normal, bad.
Okay yeah, side note, Nate
might be away for a while.
So let me know if you have any
ideas for a replacement host.
- That's ominous, do you think he's dying?
- He's always so sick, probably arthritis.
- Wait what?
Nate's job's up for grabs?
So like I could own you guys?
- I found a penny.
(upbeat music)
- Hey crazy running into you here.
- In my office?
- Totally right.
Listen, I think we both are
in agreement that I should be
the one who gets Nate's job.
- Why's that?
- Because I, Jordan
Mendoza am a cultural icon.
Did you know I'm dating
Jack Nicholson's niece?
- You are?
- Well not exactly.
I have been catfishing her
for weeks as Logan Paul
so I'm close.
By the way I'm gonna need to be reimbursed
for facial reconstructive surgery.
- Yeah, no I see see
where you're going Ron.
Let me call you back.
- The water cooler,
classic place for an office conversation.
You know I've got a little
experience leading conversations
if you know what I mean.
I'm an expert, climate, immigration, oil.
- Well typically on our pop
culture show we avoid politics,
but if you have big ideas,
let's talk about them right now.
- Right now?
- Yeah right now.
- Sure.
Climate is good.
Immigration, pretty good.
Oil,
is bad.
- Go.
- Fine.
So stupid.
I don't even know why you
have this in your office.
- [Plaid Shirt] You know why.
- I believe I misunderstood
the assignment.
(upbeat jazz music)
- Please, allow me,
just the kind of leadership
you can expect from me.
That was my father's stapler.
- So when does that pay bump kick in?
Because I'm kinda going
through a bit of a lawsuit see,
I took a credit card from
a guy who I hooked up with,
but I let him do anal you know?
And plus I'm not responsible, I was drunk.
- Hannah what's in that cup?
- Water, that happens
to smell like alcohol.
So let's share social security numbers.
You go first.
- Please go.
- Fine.
- Psst,
down here.
Step into my office.
- This is my office.
- Then why am I under your desk dummy?
Look, I know you want Nate gone,
and I'm telling ya, I can
do it clean, no witnesses.
- Oh my God, I do not want Nate dead.
- Really?
Then why did I think you did?
- I have no idea.
- Huh.
Anyway, your feet stink, and I love it.
- Thank you all for bombarding me,
but it turns out Nate will
not be leaving after all.
- Whoa, way to beat that arthritis bro,
I always knew you could do it.
- I didn't have arthritis.
- You know I once hooked up
with a guy who had arthritis,
still get flareups.
- I think the horse that
kicked me had arthritis.
That's why I foam at the mouth.
- None of you know what arthritis is.
- Look I wasn't sick,
I was gone because I thought
that I was up for a job
in Logan Paul's squad, would've been cool.
But it turns out it was just an imposter.
So looks like I'm stuck
here with you morons.
- What?
That's so weird.
Don't give up though,
you should definitely keep
Venmoing that guy money.
- I don't know, I've
already lost like $4,000,
wait, how'd you know I Venmo'd him money?
- (laughs) Shut up.
- Jordan!
(smooth jazz music)